it's good to be the king and no other
franchise reigns supreme like the fbi
universe we don't have any proof but i'm
guessing the answer is yes
cbs just renewed all three shows fbi fbi
most wanted and fbi international for
new seasons coming this fall
but first they air back to back to back
finales on may 24th hey stop
it's just it sounds you know such an
insane feat that we're trying to do
first up is the flagship show
celebrating the end of its fourth season
we thought we were gonna die
yeah we are
but it looks like we're diving right in
meanwhile fbi most wanted is coming off
an emotional goodbye for one of its own
after three seasons julian mcmahon
exited the series making way for its new
star dylan mcdermott for me it was the
best case scenario as the tv veteran
tells it joining the team couldn't have
gone smoother the show was always up and
running that it was successful the
formula was working and i knew i studied
the show so i knew walking into it
exactly what it was and exactly what i
wanted to do so i have to say it was
really seamless
[Music]
the debut of fbi international last year
took the franchise worldwide i have eyes
on you the whole way
and the spin-off even films overseas an
important detail for executive producer
dick wolf the basic difference is
it's not shot in america
and that's a huge
difference it is international fbi
international so here we are going
globally
and the fbi universe is putting down
roots all three shows have been renewed
for not one but two more seasons
cheers
[Music]
you